hi everyone great to see you all here as
you just heard my name is Olivia Gunton
and I'm a data scientist at tech CEO
we're an Augmented writing start-up in
downtown Seattle and to give you an idea
of what augmented writing is about
imagine if every time you wrote
something you knew who is going to
respond and why and that's what text do
is all about so today I want to tell you
about what I think is a really cool and
interesting design question that we have
to grapple with which is when you're
designing a system that's based in
machine learning how does your design
decision have to change if you don't
just want to be good at predicting
outcomes from inputs but you also want
to be able to give real-time automated
actionable guidance to humans so to
frame this I want to talk about some
different styles of machine learning
that we've seen over the years I think
when a lot of people think of machine
learning they think about the one on the
left here the black box style the idea
is that with all the processing power
that we have we want to build we want to
let our models become as complex that
they need to be to be most predictive so
an example here from the user
perspective is the Google search ranking
algorithm if I enter a search term into
Google I'm not seeing information about
why the number one page is ranked as
number one and that's by design and
maybe I don't even want to know that
information what's most important to me
is is that the page that I want to click
on but then when we start to apply
machine learning to scenarios where the
risk of making a bad recommendation is
much higher then we start to have a
requirement for our models to be
explainable and I'm using ways as an
example here because it's an app that we
probably all have on our phones
so when you see ways this recommendation
about what route you should take there's
a lot of information
in there about some of the reasons why
it's recommending that route and that
might include properties of the route as
well as information that's been added by
the users but another great example of
this is the book recommendations in
Amazon so you know when you're looking
at one book or you thought something you
see a bunch of lists at the bottom that
say people who bought the book that you
just bought often buy this other book so
that's giving you insight directly into
why this recommendation is being made
and why you should trust it and I think
as we start to apply machine learning
more and more to even more high stakes
realms like medicine we see a lot more
need for our models to be explainable we
need to know exactly why they're making
the predictions they're making we need
to know when and whether we can trust
them and we need to be able to fix those
problems if it's making an error in a
place that we really care about so I
want to argue that there's a third type
of machine learning and that is when you
when you not only want to introspect on
the model but you want to be able to
automatically give guidance to people
and this is coming up in a lot of
applications where we're using machine
learning for human productivity tools
and I guess the the characteristics of
these applications is a lot of what
effect the outcome is almost human art
and judgment as well as skill so our
example and text view is writing when
you write something it you know that has
an outcome like a job description like
you see here it matters what what kind
of patterns are going to be predictive
of good outcomes and you also want to be
able to preserve your unique voice as
you're writing it you don't want to just
have some program that spits out the
ideal job description because you know
you're communicating with humans so you
want something that's going to be
meaningful to them so what happens here
is as you're typing or as you paste in
your job listing you're getting a score
that represents how well your job
listing is likely to do on a sir
a bunch of different outcomes like time
to fill and how many people will apply
and how many qualified people will apply
and some guidance on the right side and
overlay it on the text that that
augments your writing experience so you
are constantly getting this updated
guidance to making your job listing
better the score and the guidance is
updating in real time as you type and
that's happening automatically so what I
want to argue today is that when you
want to design a system like this the
design choices are actually completely
different than when you're designing a
black box system and there are three
characteristics here one is the system
needs to be built using features that
are directly related to the concepts
that humans are going to be
understanding and that you want to be
guiding them on number two it needs to
be trained on data that represents the
the complete universe of inputs that you
expect to receive so not just the
initial input but what people are likely
to do when they're trying to follow your
guidance and number three you need
learning whoops to be able to feed your
users choices and behavior back into the
system to make it and the guidance
better so for anyone who is in the last
session this will look familiar I'm also
going to be using the amidst handwritten
numerals data set as a toy example to
talk about how you would build such a
system and I'm actually going to
constrain it even further I want to talk
about how do we classify a one versus a
seven and actually further how do I
recognize that a user has input a one
and then guide them into turning it into
a seven or writing a seven instead if
you want motivation you can imagine
that's how many cupcakes you get if you
write that number or how many briskets
if you're not into cupcakes you know
so let's start with the one of the most
widely known ways to attack this problem
using artificial neural networks and
specifically using tensor flow for this
it's so well known that this is tensor
flows but they're beginner and they're
expert tutorials are based in this data
set and and this kind of tool is known
to be really good at being able to
classify these kinds of handwritten
numerals the idea for anyone who's not
familiar with it is that we have the
numeral as an array of pixel values and
through this through these successive
layers of artificial neurons features
are being automatically learned by the
system that help predict the label and
it's supposed to be kind of a loose
model for how we think some parts of the
brain work so here's the code straight
out of the tutorial I'm not going to go
through every line of code in this
presentation but I'll try to highlight
the important parts so there it is you
can see that accuracy I think they're
metric here is just proportion of right
answers to wrong answers and it's very
high I think a C is also around this
level and this isn't even the best that
you can get with an artificial neural
network on this problem but you know
that's pretty good okay so we have
something where we can really clearly
and easily classify a one versus a seven
but what if we want to know now why
what's happening inside well we can look
at tensor board which is a tool that's
specifically designed to introspect on
tensor flow models and there's a lot of
information here but if you can imagine
trying to interpret this as an end user
who's not an expert you can see you
actually need a lot of really
specialized knowledge just to read and
interact with this and be able to make
decisions on this basis so while this is
great for the people who are developing
models it's not the right tool for
producing guidance for
users and even if we were to learn a
really simple model using tensorflow and
just look at the softmax layer at the
end where we can see basically
probabilities of various pixels being
associated with that label okay this is
kind of more readable to me as a human
but first of all it's hard to tell how I
would give someone specific guidance
from this and then also because we're
just flattening out all the
probabilities it kind of collapses some
key information like I think it makes it
look too necessary to have a foot on the
7 or it doesn't reflect that maybe you
can have a foot on the 1 but then you
also need to have the notch at the top
okay so this may be one of the most
predictive models is not the right way
to go about this problem if we want to
give guidance so let's try a totally
different algorithm that is known to be
really easy to introspect on and so the
idea of a decision tree classifier is
you have your two classes red and blue
in this example and at each step the
algorithm is finding the feature and the
feature value that give the best
separation of the data and it produces
basically a flowchart for classifying
things into roughly one class or the
other and this is really easy to do in
Python you think scikit-learn
so here I've just cut the MS dataset
into just the ones in the sevens and I
train a model and hey I am actually
getting pretty good AC on this probably
not ever as good as I'll get with
tensorflow but but this is decent but
then when we visualize the decision tree
even though it's clear to me what the
logic is here let's look at what it's
telling us well how do I get to a seven
okay is pixel number 378 is less than or
equal to 145 point five then yes then
pixel 157 is it less than or equal to 35
okay clearly this is not advice that I
want to give to user when I when they
write a one and I want to tell them how
to make a seven they're not going to be
tweaking pixel values and this is even
if they could follow this it would be
really a burden to try to follow so it's
time to engineer some better features
and to do this I'm using two tools
mostly OpenCV that made a lot of the
feature engineering on this particular
problem really easy just a matter of
setting the parameters that I wanted and
tuning it so that it was producing the
outputs that I wanted and I use cited at
one point for for one thing that I
thought it did better than OpenCV these
are both pip installable there's great
documentation online and so you'll be
able to do all the stuff I'm doing here
so just as a reminder we're starting
with this numeral as an area of pixel
values and I want to get from that to
something that other that laypeople that
other humans can easily think about and
act on locally I am a human myself so I
have some intuitions about what that
might be and when I think about numbers
some of the things that come to mind are
drying lines and drying corners these
these are the the concepts that we use
to think about drawing so it would be
great if we could give advice directly
targeted at those concepts so here's
just setting up everything I'm going to
use for this problem and I'm keeping all
of the numerals in a panda's data frame
I'm also a pandas fan for what it's
worth so for my first step is just to
resize the images they they come as 28
by 28 pixel arrays and I wanted
something that was bigger so I could
easily visualize and kind of debug what
I was working with and so first step
when you have a noisy input is just
squint a little harder I apply some blur
and so here we get that's the original
seven and we're
turning it into something that's a
little more vague a little less specific
and then I threshold it on using CB 2's
threshold to just make it a stark
black-and-white figure so it's really
clear where the where the shape is and
where the edges are
and then my final step is to skeletonize
it so I'm basically sending it down to
the one pixel wide central structure of
the numeral and this was the point where
I fence I could image to do better than
OpenCV the opencv skeleton had all these
branches and artifacts coming off of it
and for my purpose I just wanted
something that cleanly represented the
structure of the shape so that's the
choice that I made and there's only one
little tail on there that didn't really
cause any problems and so now that I
have all the steps I can put them
together into a pipeline and apply that
to every image that I have in my data
frame and you can see the result at the
end so now I have these nice skeletons
that really clearly and generally
represent the shape of that particular
hand-drawn numeral and it's really easy
because there are one pixel wide for me
to now find lines and corners in them
okay so first step is line detection
again OpenCV has the probabilistic Hough
line transform the idea is that for each
point in the image you're you're
basically graphing the origin and the
angle of all the lines that could
possibly intersect with it and then
seeing where all of those graphs
intersect and that's one way of finding
the lines and the probabilistic version
just has some some greater efficiency in
performance so I'm applying that one
thing I found is that this function
tended to return a bunch of lines that
when I visualize them they look like
they were all right on top of each other
it seemed like extra lines to me and I
just wanted to represent what the what
the user would see so I had to introduce
the concept of our two lines close
to consider equal and for that I just
looked at is the origin within a certain
distance and is the angle within a
certain number of degrees and if so then
I only keep one of those so then I put
everything through that filter and I
save my lines in dict form so that I can
easily access the attributes like the
coordinates of the origin the
coordinates of the end point and the
length and the angle so here's the
result you can see the detected lines
that the filtered detected lines
overlaid in green and the dictionary
representations at the bottom and now
that I've done that for all my images
it's really easy to count stuff about
them and this can start to become
features that I use later
so right here I'm counting are they how
many are horizontal and how many are
vertical within a certain amount of
wiggle room so now we turn to corners
which seemed like the next cool thing to
try this is probably the least
intuitively named function in OpenCV
instead of corner detection it's called
good features to track so now you know
what that means I mean they are good
features to track but I only know that
after using that and so here I'm doing a
similar thing I didn't have to do any
filtering but I want to put them into a
dictionary form so that it's really easy
for me to work with their attributes and
here's the result overlaid with the dict
representation and now I can count
things about the corners too so the
first thing I wanted to try besides the
number of corners was what quadrant of
the image is the corner appearing in
and now now that I have all these
features that humans can understand
without any special training I can use
those as features to the same decision
tree classifier same same parameters
same depth and everything and hey it's
still performing pretty well and when I
look when I introspect on what the
decision tree is it's actually telling
me things that I can use if I'm drawing
numbers check the number of horizontal
lines check how many corners are in the
upper-left so that's a really great
first step but there's one issue here
which is number of horizontal lines
seems to be separating the ones from the
seventh really well and a little too
well I kind of know this is more complex
than just how many horizontal lines you
draw on the page and when I think about
what a user might do if they drew one
and I said draw one more horizontal line
maybe they'll make a seven but maybe
they'll make a capital L instead so
clearly I'm not really reflecting
everything that users could do in
response to my guidance but that could
be easy to deal with maybe I'll just
stick a bunch of capital elves into my
training data and label them as not
seven and see if I can learn okay what
makes a seven besides the number of
horizontal lines again OpenCV makes this
really easy to rotate an image and here
you can see an example of seven rotated
and turned into an L and sure enough
what comes out of this looks like it
reflects the complexity a lot better we
did take a little performance hit but I
feel that this is going to reflect
better what I expect to see from users
as they're following my guidance and
actually if I just add one more feature
and a couple more levels to the decision
tree I can get back up above 90 so I now
have a way to continue to refine and
tune this model and get more and more
predictive and I'm still basing this on
features that I can directly use in my
guidance so let's talk about how we
would construct guidance in this case if
we if we see that this is a 1 the model
knows what the future values of a 7 are
likely to be given this initial input
and can take the difference between the
current input and the target once you
have that you could see how you could
one-to-one map this to prose guidance
that you could show a user in the UI
that they could follow and have a really
good chance of producing the desired
input if you want you can also make UI
decisions too to kind of indicate some
of the same things doesn't just have to
be words you can use images or
highlighting to help reinforce what
you're trying to guide them to do in a
system like this you want to have a
mechanism for communicating low
confidence so let's say we based on our
model we can't tell whether this is the
1 or a 7 and we think it may not clearly
be a 7 so that's indicated by the the
features that come out and the
probabilities that come out and in the
UI you can make a choice to change the
way that you express that in your
language or in the visual aspects of
your UI and finally we need a way to
observe what users are doing and feed
that back in to what we learn so in this
case if I give the user the same
guidance that I constructed before and
this is what they do they draw this kind
of sideways lambda I can see what I of
the system can see that the future
values are different than what I
expected when I took the dish that tells
me that the guidance wasn't solid in the
way that I expected so ideally when this
happens it would be great to also know
the outcome of this shape is this a new
way of writing 7 and if you write this
you're going to get the 7 cupcakes
or briskets or is it is it incorrect and
is our guidance insufficient to helping
a human get to the goal of drawing a
seven so now that I've shown you a toy
example I want to show you an example of
a much more complicated system that's
built on these principles so this is
text iou's job listing editor and i'm
going to paste in my listing and i had
an internet blip but i'm going to paste
in the listing again and as you can see
the scores and guidance are updating as
I paste it in and then if I so I'm
looking at the guidance then I see okay
I probably need to have more bulleted
content for my job listing to perform
well so if I want to add something maybe
say you need to proactively offer
solutions to problems as part of this
job then the guidance is updating live
in response to all the changes I made so
I added words I added a bullet point I
added some corporate jargon here and
that's all being taken into account and
automatically helping me get this
towards closer to 100 and then if I want
to look at the suggestions for replacing
this phrase that's likely to make my
listing perform worse but the system
does not have complete confidence that
this is a good replacement I have a
mechanism for giving that feedback and
this is all built in Python by the way
all the back end and we do all our data
stuff in Python
so if you've not even this this is the
amazing team of people that I get to
work with every day and Chris Harlan our
director of data engineering is over
there in the audience and Karen
Schneider our CEO is even here really
happy to see you guys
and I wanted to say if any of this is
intriguing to you if you can get
something that you might want to work on
then come see us we're hiring thank you
well thank you very much Lizzie for that
hang on once again I will be taking
questions on Twitter sameen Twitter
cooperates which is always a good hope
so while we wait for questions to come
in on Twitter um where have you we're
also using the use of this kind of
guidance other than our CEO textio and
to try to get yourself more cupcakes hmm
I wish I had that system I'm going on I
you know I can't an example isn't coming
to mind this we may be the the first
people to be doing this exact kind of
thing and it's really exciting and fun
to work on definitely not a bad problem
ask so I saw you recommending open CV
and so I could learn it's like image is
there any other libraries that we should
probably keep an eye out for consider
using when we're trying to figure out
how to do this and values from my
perspective also just kind of figure out
when is the best for like easy use of
decisions resources no that works in
like I'm stuff yeah I think scikit-learn
has so many things built in and the way
that open CV makes image processing that
it's really about just finding the
parameters that work well for your
problem I think that's true for all of
the algorithms built into scikit-learn
so but and it's well documented so that
that's really the core of what I would
recommend okay I get Twitter to refresh
it's time to give me Hetal know if
anyone's working on the Twitter app make
it refresh faster if this fails yes oh
here we go
so one question we do have is these
decision trees in production and how do
you dress their tendencies to overfit or
if you can use them in production or if
you don't what do you use yeah I'm not
going to go into the specifics of what
we use in texty oh I would say that i
chose decision trees here because
they're really easy to kind of
intuitively get even if you haven't seen
them before and they're kind of the
classic example of what you would use if
you want to introspect on your model but
they're not appropriate for all
applications
another question we had was could you
talk about applying this guidance to
education and learning perhaps or if you
have any opinion on this - to human
education so so the idea is you're
guiding the learner or you're guiding
the teacher I don't know of course I can
see I mean that's that it that's a
really good example though before
teaching because if we could have a
robot teach then you know we would
probably have that happen but there's so
much art and there's so much real-time
responsiveness that goes into being a
teacher I guess you know in theory a lot
of these human activities could be
people could get access to more data and
and help making decisions through some
kind of augmented system the way that
we're doing augmented writing I mean I
know personally while I was watching
your talk watching you try to guide
someone how to draw one from a seven
immediately made me think of the old
meme of how to draw an owl throughout
one circle draw another circle dozen all
the rest the
being kind of along those lines of just
teaching some particular how to draw
then such or help people learn how to do
that sort of thing yeah and you need to
make sure that you account for all the
steps that they might need to follow
from beginning to end so just like you
said you can't have a future did they
draw the owl not very helpful
yeah I'm really predicted though yeah
exactly
did you finish yes or no another
question was do you have any guidelines
for how to pick good features um that's
a really good question I think I would
start by casting the net wide like I
said if we're dealing with a problem
where humans are going to be judging the
outputs and that's part of the outcome
and that's whether it's deciding how
many cupcakes to give you or deciding
whether to apply to your job your your
intuition about what's meaningful in
that space is going to be really helpful
in giving you a and then I would say try
to come up with everything you can and
one of the wonderful things about
machine learning is you don't have to
decide in advance what you think the
weights of those different features
they're going to be you can learn
whether they're actually important for
the problem or not another question we
received was what kinds of applications
you think guys face ml is most relevant
for although that's all it goes along
with the previous question I heard
someone say something okay so I believe
there's one question in the audience I
can repeat if you want to speak loudly
enough I can say it again so this case
you add
neural network with I'm a clinical model
and you are able to basically an
explainable margin special folder what
happened is they don't actually have the
same performance dual Network
outperformed by a lot so the question
was squeeze as love you showed starting
with the neural network is great in kind
of high performance levels but you can't
explain how exactly how it works and she
was able to build decision trees that
did have high performance and was
explainable the question was what do you
do when you can't get from unexplainable
to explainable and keep the same level
performance correct yes that's a great
question and I think you could attack it
from two angles one is more feature
engineering maybe you you just haven't
found the right features that are going
to be predictive of that can you care
about another thing is the the
prediction the the performance metrics
that we use don't completely describe
how useful our model is for whatever
we're trying to solve so it's possible
that you could have a situation where
you really need to be highly predictive
at one end of the spectrum and at the
other end of the spectrum of inputs you
can just get by with communicating low
confidence in your predictions so if
someone starts drawing squiggles and I
haven't learned I don't have that in my
training data I don't have a way of
knowing what that is but I can just
communicate that that's outside of what
I can give guidance about right now and
maybe have some way to steer them back
on track luckily in a lot of these
applications where your system is
collaborating and and augmenting the
experience as the human is your users
are going to be benevolent so they
really want to get to that goal of
drawing a seven so they're going to try
their best to follow your guidance and
that helps constrain the possible inputs
that you can expect in most cases
should we take one window for a comment
that I want your reaction on I think
you're at the tip of what may be the
most important problem facing neural
networks for the next 20 years
they are unexplainable - not human and
if we completely go in the world of
neural networks we may get great
predictions but we lose science we'll
lose the ability to understand what
happens and what you're trying to do is
be is to build a bridge between the
human and the Indian even though that
source we have used other modeling
techniques that may not be quite as
accurate but hopefully are sufficiently
accurate but this seems to me to be like
what you you're on the most important
problems related to their own I agree
it's an important problem sorry states a
statement so the comment is basically
neural networks because they're
unexplainable can be viewed as almost
harmful to science because they're not
explainable and what we'll be presenting
here in terms of trying to make such
systems explainable is really important
and potentially something very important
going forward and if I said that
correctly and the question basically was
what's your response to that statement
yeah I I agree this is something that a
lot of people are thinking about for the
reason I talked about earlier well for
one reason that we're starting to apply
these approaches to ever more
high-stakes applications and also for
for some activities like writing I think
it's really exciting that we can have a
system that is partnering with the human
and not replacing the human because I
think we see we can't adequately replace
a human in some domains
like we've got one word yeah there's
there are some ones asking if you can
actually demo tech CEO to show a close
to perfect job listing that resulted
from actual going from not so great to
actually very good I'm sure I don't know
if it went from not so great but I can
show you we we make a point of making
sure that all of our listings score well
and text you
so just to plug our hiring again so you
can see here some of the reasons why
text EO is predicting that this listing
will feel quickly and and I hope that
answers the question were there any
questions that happen to be that yes
Isles the world we're trying to get
people to a job of this kind of like we
develop models but we need an actual
person to look
some output have degrees or what I
brought have you found anything that
helps to get people to actually use kind
of guided model or comment on getting
adoption of it um okay so the question
was basically how do you help drive
adoption of this a guidance approach
yeah I think the key for us is when
you're using text EO it doesn't feel
like you're interacting with a machine
learning model
it just feels organic like you're
writing and then you have all of this
additional guidance and information
overlaid on top of it I would say from a
user perspective that seems ideal what's
the what's your domain Healthcare okay
so like diagnostics and okay identifying
high-risk patients that's really cool I
would love to hear more about that we
have one more raised hand in the back of
yep Twitter eat natto
/ okay so the question was this seems to
be applicable to all kinds of writing do
we see a risk of feature space explosion
when we when we move to other domains
and I totally agree and that's one of
the things I'm most excited about any
kind of writing that has an outcome you
could see how this would be really
useful I would say that's what my main
concern I would think one of the hardest
things is getting good data so we can
get really good data about listings and
hiring outcomes from our customers it's
harder to see in some domains that we
might be really interested in how we
would get the outcomes to go along with
the data and how to make that process of
providing data really easily as far as
the features I would say you know a lot
of language has a lot of features in
common but obviously you have to refine
this process based on new domains that
you move to okay yeah I think I missed a
question but it was about applications
which I think we've covered
I believe that's everything so unless
there's any other questions in the room
yes
and we will increase
Ivo confusing mean for celebrity tour
club where the actions are the ejection
to view and then to get I've been to
course having a midlife crisis and a
paradigm
um so I think that's quiet okay so yes
thank you
the question is have we tried to use
reinforcement learning I I would say it
that's part of the idea of having these
learning loops that are observing
aspects of the users behavior in
response to guidance the the time scale
which we might get complete data about
the outcomes was slightly different so
we have to take a number of different
approaches to knit that together into
the system that's going to be really
predictive and performance and just to
give everyone the six minutes until the
next session and if Julie's in the room
the next speaker please feel free to
come on up and get ready and we'll keep
take questions if Olivia's amenable to
it and we keep it up so take Megan oh
thank you
after these two a lot of looking for
teachers in problems I mean that solving
how the colleges because of that right
so this is talking about the earlier
days of machine learning before we had
really complex artificial neural network
models and how does this differ I would
say we have we have the benefit of
explainable features but also the
whatever predictive power and processing
power and complexity we need to to turn
those to learn a really predictive model
from those features so there can be more
complexity and it's not like we're
mapping out based on this job
description what are all the paths you
could take at this time to make it to
make it better but it's still founded
like you said on on explainable features
yes would it be complete by them to use
one model like a black box addiction and
I do something incredible the guy would
be right I would have liked that
scientific another report yeah and I've
heard so the question was could we use a
black box technique for the actual
prediction and another way of learning
how to give guidance I've actually seen
this mentioned in the realm of
explainable AI where you have one model
that's kind of learning learning the
structure of the other model I think
this you get into there is that the
features may be really far away from
what you're actually going to be giving
guidance about so when a human makes a
change in response to the guidance it's
not directly related to what you're
predicting on and it seems like if we
can do well enough using those direct
concepts why wouldn't we just use those
but I agree that's a really interesting
approach to yes
fifteen plan maybe you already home
daily staying in on
the recommit how do you feel that large
so the question is how do we scale our
learning loops when when our data
becomes very large I mean I think if you
think about any time that you need to be
able to scale to predict on large
amounts of data it's similar techniques
to what you would use it's it's no
different from that problem I would say
so you mentioned that there might be
other domains where finding data is
harder and I guess there has to be an
intersection like Marcus man what what
kind of doing well so the question is
what other domains might we think about
where data might be harder to get we do
have a recruiting male beta right now so
that's that's another example of some
place where you can imagine that outcome
is will someone respond or will someone
altom utley get into the hiring pipeline
and maybe that the data is a little bit
harder to get because job listings are
public by their nature but males are
spent privately so that's that's the
unique problem to that domain I should
probably let the adult figuring it on
but thank you guys so much and I would
love to talk to you more after the
session
[Applause]